la justice a des doutes la cour de
révision a annulé la condamnation de
patrick dils à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité pour le meurtre de deux
enfants à montigny les metz en moselle
en 1986 patrie 10 sera rejugé et pour
l'instant ils restent en prison au
portage valérie ermite avec vincent
fourcade et emmanuel bec
la salle d'audience est bondée le public
ne s'y est pas trompé l'instant est
rarissime
la cour de révision annule la
condamnation de patrick dils demande à
ce qu'il soit reçu j'ai tout en refusant
sa remise en liberté
c'est ce qu'on attendait que enfin le
jugement soit cassée et que patrick se
reconnut maintenant présumé innocent
nous savons qu'il n'a jamais commis ce
double crime
cette fois-ci gérer la vérité ton
marchiol polarité il sera jugé dans un
délai extrêmement rapide par la cour
d'assises de la marne
siégeant à reims et à partir de là est
évident qu'il sera acquitté
d'interview en interview par henry
avocat répète ce même mot historique
l'histoire
vin très long combat familiale et
judiciaire
1989 patrick dils est condamné à la
perpétuité pour le meurtre de deux
enfants
dils a avoué mais très vite s'est
rétracté une première demande de
révision est rejetée car il n'y a aucun
élément nouveau en 1997
un gendarme de rennes jean mamac brasles
entend parler de la sphère dils les deux
meurtres pour lesquels il a été condamné
lui rappelle soudain quelque chose
et pour cause francis heaulme tueur en
série notoire lui en avait déjà parlé
cinq ans plus tôt heaulme lui avait
décrit une voie ferrée à
montigny-lès-metz et deux enfants
retrouvés morts
à l'époque le gendarme avait bien sûr
cherché mais n'avait rien trouvé
car patrick dils ayant déjà été condamné
l'affairé s'est classé et retirait des
fichiers des enquêteurs c'est ce nouvel
élément la présence avérée de francis
heaulme sur le lieu du crime qui a
conduit la cour de révision a demandé la
tenue d'un nouveau procès la fin de 14
ans de procédures pour la famille 10 et
la saveur retrouver un verre de
champagne